مشاهدينا الكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
مرحبا بكم في لقاء خاص مع السيد الفريق
اول
عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس المجلس السياده
الانتقالي في السودان
وقائد الجيش السوداني مرحبا بك سعاده
الفريق
هذا اليوم والاتفاق الذي تم بين المقاولون
العسكري وبعض القوه المدنيه هل انت على
ثقه بان هذا الاتفاق سيحدث
اختراقا في الازمه السودانيه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم السلام عليكم تحيه
لقناه الجزيره والتحيه للمشاهدين الكرام
اول ما تم اليوم هو ليس اتفاق بين
المقاولون العسكري وقوه سياسي ما تم اليوم
هو توافق بين كل هذه المكونات اذا كانت
قوه عسكريه او قوه مدنيه على قضايا نظن
انها كانت السبب في تعطيل مسار الانتقال
ليس اتفاقا ثنائيا لكن هو مجموع لقضايا
ستطرح يتم تداول حولها حتى نخرج منها
بمخرجات تدين من الفتره الانتقاليه وتحافظ
عليها وتنقلنا الى همم مع بعض هذه الفتره
الانتقاليه ولكن هنالك من يغسل انتاسه ما
هي الضمانات همم تنبع من اسرارنا تنبع من
عزيتنا تنبع من رغبتنا في اننا نستمر في
هذا الامر ونذل لكل العقبات الذي يمكن ان
تعترون سياسيه
كبيره وواسعه رفضت هذا الاتفاق منها
الحريه والتغيير همم
الكتله الديمقراطيه منها الشرق السودان
منها الاتحاد الاصل منها كتله نداء
السودان هل
يصمت هذا الاتفاق في مواجهه هذه الكتله
همم انا اقول لك بصراحه يمكن نفسك كتله
الديمقراطيه ايضا تقدمت باعلان همم
ايطاليا والاعلان سياسي مطابق لو 100% 95%
اللي ما قدم الان او اللي ما طرح اليوم
لذلك لا ارى انه هنالك عقبه في تكامل هذه
الاعلانين لكن همم القوه السياسيه عندنا
او بعض القوى ربما تكابر ربما ترى انها
ضروره وجودها في كبيره القياده ربما ترى
انها يجب ان تكون هي في المقدمه هذه
التشاكس هو
الفتره الانتقاليه وسيضر بها في المستقبل
ونرتضي بما مطروح ونجلس حوله اذا كانت هي
قدمت ما يعني ما يقابل 95% في توافق لماذا
اخترتم هذه القوه التي قدموه بالامس همم
وهذا الذي تم تم النقاش تم النقاش حوله
منذ فتره ليست قصيره همم انا ذكرت لهم ان
ما قدمتموه طابق لماذا لا تسحب وتجلسوا مع
الفريق الاخر وتاتون سويا وعندما ذهبوا من
كل فريق ذهب الى همم سبيله هذا الامر همم
البلد لا تتحمله الوطن لا يتحمله لا يجب
ان نمضي واذا كان هنالك وطني يحب ان همم
يقضي البلد ويقضي وطنه يجب ان يستمر
الفريق الاخر واتفقت معه وصلت معه الى
اتفاق فلماذا لم تحاورك مكون عسكري اولئك
المخالفين للفريق الاخر نحن يوميا نتحدث
معهم بضروره التوحد ضروره ثم الشملي كقوه
سياسيه ضروريه القوه التي نتحدث عنها الان
همم تشمل كل القوى التي كانت
قبل ابريل 2019 وهذا الامر منصوص عليه في
وسائق التفاوض ان القوه الماضيه او التي
يمكن ان تكون جزء من هذا الاتفاق ومفتوح
هذا الاتفاق لها لتلحق به كل القوى قوه
الحريه والتغيير كما كانت في ابريل 2019
اضافه للقوه الثوريه الغير موقعه على
اعلام هو الحريه والتغيير والقوه التي
تراضينا وراينا انها ضروريه لاكمال المشهد
السياسي ولتوسيع هذا المشاركه اللي هي
الاتحاد الاصل والمؤتمر الشعبي وجماعه
السنه الان انتم وصلتم للاتفاق مع هذه
القوه عبر حوار هل ستحاورون بقيه القوى
الرافضه لهذا الاتفاق للتضموها الى
الاتفاق كمكون عسكريه
ايضا سياسيا وذكرنا النادي الايطالي
يتطابق اذهبوا اجلسوا مع المجموعه الاخرى
واتونا سويا اذا لماذا لم تنتظرها هؤلاء
ليذهبوا ويجلسوا معه نحن عام كامل ننتظر
هذا التوافق والقوه المطروحه الان في
الورق في الورقه هم نفسهم غير مقصرين منها
موجودين اسماءهم موجوده
وتنظيمات وموجوده وفي اي وقت ممكن يجوا
يفتحوا بهذا الامر انت كنت تشتريت ان
تسليم السلطه المدنيين على توافق بين جميع
القوه المدنيه ما عدا المؤتمر الوطني هل
تحقق ذلك الان القوه التي اتفقنا عليها
الان تطابق تماما ما قلناهم لكن اذا كان
هنالك ما لا يريد ان ياتي هل الوطن تنظر
بلد تنتظر حتى ياتي
سنمضي مع من يعلي المساله الوطنيه والشان
الوطني ونرى ان في هذه الخطوه انقاذ حاله
الوطن بهذا الموقف التهامكم البعض وطلب
منكم ان الجيش يجب ان يقف على يقف على
مسافه واحده من كل القوى السياسيه
يرى عندكم
واتفقتم مع دون ان تفاوض الاخرين
فيما يساعد على تدمير البلد نحن على مسافه
واحده في مصلحه السودان لكن في اي امر ضد
السودان
التوافق في الفتره الانتقاليه الان في قوه
كبيره هي خارج هذه القاعده هذه القاعده
مفتوحه الان للجميع وكل من يريد ان يلحق
بهذا الامر يستطيع يعني شروط هذا الاتفاق
او التوافق يعني ان يلحق بهذا الامر على
شروط هذا الحضور هذه النقاط مطروحه للنقاش
يحضر ويشتري في الوراث يشتري في المؤتمرات
اشترك برايه ويعدل ما مكتوبه الان هذا
الامر الذي اتفقنا عليه الان ليس نهائيا
هو امر يطرح وسيقول فيه سودانيون رايهم
ومن ثم يتحول الى دستور او الى همم سائق
تحكم الفتره الانتقاليه اذا لم يحضر
المخالفون الان الى نقاش او حضروا النقاش
واختلفوا مع التوافق الذي تم اليوم هل ترى
ان هذا التوافق كافي لتسليم السلطه
المدنيين نحن همم
دائما الامور التي همم من المسلمات ان يتم
التوافقوا لها لا يمكن ان نفعل مثلا
انتقاليه دون توافق لا يمكن ان همم
العدل مثلا او بدون مشاوره تصلحها اصحاب
المصلحه لا يمكن ان نقوم سلام جوبا بدون
التشاور مع همم
المتضررين واصحاب المصلحه واصراف الاتفاق
لا يمكن ان لا يمكن انجز هذه الاعمال بدون
ان نتفق عليها مع من نتفق عليها هذه القوه
السياسيه والقوه ذات الشان بصيلها لكن هنا
له قوه ذات شان ربما خرجت على هذا الاتفاق
يعني الان انت ترى في هذا اليوم الذي تم
فيه توافق هنالك حاله بتاعه انقسام واضحه
في المجتمع السوداني فكيف يمكن ان مثلا
الشرق الشرق قوه قوه قويه ولا اثر وكانت
مؤثره جدا حتى في في في في ما قبل 25
اكتوبر كيف يمكن تجاوزه في هذا الاتفاق
حتى
السودان هنالك فقط مقابله هنالك ربما امور
سياسيه
في هذا الامر لكن موضوع الشرق مشار اليه
بفاغره كامله انه يجب ان يحل موضوع الشرق
بالتشاور مع اهله ومع اصحاب المصلحه و
هنالك بما يحقق عليهم الاستقرار والتنميه
لكن همم
كل المجموعات التي لا تريد ان تحضر ربما
لديها اجنده لديها اغراض لكن هي الموضوعات
المطروحه الان تعالج معظم القضايا
السودانيه طبعا نفس هذا الاتهام يرد الى
المجموعات التي اتفقت لها اجنده ومالك قوه
خارجيه مثلا القوه المعارضه تقول ان هذا
اتفاق يعني ثنائي واخصائى
فيه امور تخالف للمصلحه الوطنيه نعم مثل
ماذا مثلا ان يقف الجميع على التغليف
الدوله على مسافه واحده من كل الاديان هذا
الشعب السوداني شعب مسلم بنسبه 98% الا
يعرض ذلك هويه الشعب والثقافه
حول هذا الامر
قبل ان يجلس يتحاور فيه يجب ويقول رايه
وحتى اذا رفض راي كل دي موقف لكن من
البدايه يعني ما تشاور ولا تحاور
احكم مسبقا مثلا هل فعلا حدث املاء وفرض
هذا الاتفاق من الخارج
من الخارج نحن وطنيين نحن سودانيين نحن
نقدر المسؤوليه الوطنيه نقدر الهم الوطني
نقدر حتى قيمه السياده وقتلنا عمرنا كله
من اجلس في هذا الوطنيه لا يمكن ان نقبل
باي املاءات ولا يمكن نسمح لاحد بان يفرض
علينا املاءات من الخارج هذا الامر مردود
على كل من يقول هذا الامر هناك حديث حول
الاتفاق مثلا ما يسمى بالمجلس العالي
المؤقت الذي يعينه القوه الموقعه على
الاعلان الدستوري
الذين يعرضونه يرون ان في هذا تسييس عالي
للقضاء وبالتالي كل المواصفات القضائيه
ستكون مسيسه وفقا المصدر الذي عين هذا
المجلس نحن فقط
الان كم المؤسسه عسكريه
ناقشنا الامور التي تهمه المؤثره العسكريه
نحن نرى ان كل الامور الاخرى لديها
المختصين لديها المقتدرين لديها اصحاب
شانها هم يناقشونها ويصلوا فيها الى رؤيه
لكن هذه الامور المطروحه لست نهائيا يجب
ان نتحدث ونتحدث في موضوع هذه الامور
المطروحه ليست نهائيا هذا الامر مطروح
الانقاش في مطروح للحوار وكل من يريد ان
يدلي برايه ويدري بحديثه يجب ان يحضروا
ويذكر ذلك لكن النظر نعارب في الوسائل
الاعلام في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
والفرصه متاحه لكل التجليس وتقول رايك
وتقوي»
هي الاربع الجيش والدعم السريع وجهاز
الامن والمخابرات والشرطه وفي مكان اخر
يقول ان الدعم السريع تابع للجيش السوداني
اين موقع الدعم السريع الدعم السريع يتبع
للقوات المسلحه لديه قانون صدر في فتره
سابقه هذا القانون هو يوصف وضعيته وهذه
التعريفات اخذت من قانون الدعم السريع اظن
ان اذا كانت هنالك تعديلات اذا كانت هنالك
اموس تجرى كل هذه الامور يمكن ان يتم اذا
كانت في ورش العمل اذا كانت في القوانين
المستقبليه لكن الان في قانون بيوصف هذه
الوضعيه وموجود اذا كان في اخطاء هذه
الاخطاء وتقيبت من النظام السابق نظام
السابق نفس هذا التوصيف موجود بغانمه
وهل في فرصه لتصحيح اخطاء النظام السابق
نحن الان نعمل على هذا التصحيح
كل موضوعاتني اذا كانت العسكريه سياسيه
الاقتصاديه ون الامور التي تخدم المرحله
الانتقاليه هل من جدول زمني في تقديرك
تنتهي بهذه المشاورات وتنتقل به السلطه
الى الى المدنيين نحن لا نريد ان نتعجل
عجل مخله لكن هذا الامر ربما التشاور فيه
القوى السياسيه بما يمكننا من ان تنجز
المطلوب بالسرعه المطلوبه وبالسرعه
اللازمه لكن هناك عسكريين همم امورنا
العسكريه واضحه ومرتبه ومتى ما بدانا
العمل او متى ما شرعنا في انجازه حسب ما
نتفق عليه لكن ليس هنالك يعني وقت معين
يمكن ان يتجاوب نتجاوز في هذه الازمه لنقل
السلطه المدنيه نحن موجودين مع بعض كلنا
بقوه مدنيه وقوه عسكريه
ان المزارع تحتاج الى الجلوس وتحديد
الاطار الزمني او تحديد الفتره الزمنيه
سنفعل ذلك
هنالك وثيقه تسربت من
الدستور المقترح
تمنح شاغلي المواقع العسكريه العليا
حصانات لكل ما تم قبل توقيع دستور الدستور
20 22 ما حقيقه ذلك طبعا هذا الامر تم
نقاشه
وهذا الامر العميل به في اكتوبر 64 كان
هنالك نص مشابه هذا النص ليس المقصود منه
حمايه اي شخص ارتكب اي جريمه هذا النص هو
لحمايه المؤسسات لحمايه الوظائف التي
تتولى اداره الدوله لكن اذا كان هنالك اي
شخص ثابته او شارك او وجهها او فعل همم لا
اظن انه هنالك جهه تستطيع ان تمنعه هذه
الحصانه سعاده الفريق الاول هنالك ناس اخر
يسمح بمحاكمه العسكريين الذين ارتكبها
جرائم ماء الا ترى ان هناك همم حصانات في
مستوى معين ولاحصانات في مستوى اخر كلام
غير صحيح كيف يمكن ان نفهم نصين احدهم
يمنع حصانات والاخر لا يمنح هذه الحسنات
بل يؤكد حتى الاخير الذي يتحدث عنه لا
يمنح نفس الحصار الحصانات الغير ممنوعه في
المناطق الاخرى لان الجرائم النصوص انه ما
في حصانات هي جرائم اتفق عليها عالميا
جرائم اللي بهذا الجماعيه وتطهير العرقي
جرائم الحرب هذه ليست مشموله بالحصانات
سيده الفريق اول ااه انت كنت طوال الفتره
ما بعد سقوط النظام السابق راس الدوله
الان مستوى الشراكه مع المدنيين في
الاتفاق الجديد على مستوى اا المجلس مجلس
مجلس الدفاع والامن ويرقصوا رئيس الوزراء
وشراكه القوات المسلحه فيه على مستوى قائد
هذه القوات وان تكون راس الدوله ما هو
موقعك الجديد في ظل هذه الاوضاع انا
حتى الان
جندي في القوات المسلحه
ظل اعمل في القوات المسلحه متى ما كان ذلك
ضروريا للمصلحه العامه ومصلحه القوات
المسلحه متى ما كان هنالك انتفاء لهذه
الضروريه
همم خارج هذه المؤسسات سيد الرئيس هنالك
قوى قيل انكم يعني كنتم تعاملون عليها في
توازن همم مدني داخل الساحه السودانيه مثل
قوه نداء السودان
وهي قوى كبيره فيها كل الطرق الصوفيه او
معظمه فيها الادارات الاهليه في ما الموقف
من هذه القوه وانت اشرتها في مواقع كثيره
جدا الى ان
الاسلاميين همم يعني كانما يريدون ان
يستخدم القوات المسلحه ما الموقف من هذه
القوه هل تصف بهذه القوه بانها قوه
الاسلاميه
نتحدث عن الاسلاميه
التي تسعى للحصول على السلطه من خلال
استخدام القوات المسلحه همم
لدينا همم ان هناك بعض هذه المجموعات تريد
ان من خلال قوات المسلحه تستعيد السلطه
وتستعيد الحكم هذا الامر لان بالنسبه لنا
واضح ونقف في وجهه لكن القوه المدنيه
الاخرى اذا كانت طرق صوفيا اداره الاهليه
هم ده من مكونات الشعب السوداني ووجودين
في اي مكان وسنه يدافع عنهم ونحميه ونقدم
لهم المساعده اللازمه هل هذا التوجه يمنع
الاسلاميين من ممارسه السياسه المدنيه
كمادانيين وكاسياسيين نحن تحدثنا عن منع
استخدام القوات المسلحه لاستله على السلطه
ولكن الان هذه القوه الاسلاميه خارج نطاق
الحوار يعني ما عدا المؤتمر الوطني ليس
هنالك حجر الان على اي قوى ما عدا المؤتمر
الوطني اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على هذه الثانيه
اخرى وشكرا لكم واعزاء المشاهدين والى ان
نلتقي في لقاء اخر شكرا